[Musique]
c'est une fonction qui incarne le
décorum et la retenue
un rôle où chaque apparition publique et
finement orchestrée mais en coulisses la
vie dans l'entourage de la gouverneure
générale serait beaucoup plus
mouvementée siby ci a recueilli des
témoignages dévastateurs comme celui de
cet ex employé du bureau de julie
payette
il y avait beaucoup de place j'ai vu des
collègues pleurait presque tout le temps
j'étais là souley rien que me cacher la
gouverneure générale aurait contribué à
un climat toxique de harcèlement et d'
abus verbal siby ci a contacté une
douzaine de sources qui ont demandé de
conserver l'anonymat par crainte pour
leur carrière
selon ces témoignages julie payette
serez prompte aux accès de colère aurait
crié contre des employés en plus de les
rabaisser et de les humilier devant les
autres membres du personnel
j'irais jusqu'à dire qu'il y avait une
victime à chaque réunion par exemple en
une seule journée
plusieurs personnes auraient quitté son
bureau les larmes aux yeux les
comportements allégués se manifesterait
particulièrement lors des voyages des
séances de débreffage à bord de l'avion
au retour aurait duré des heures
et aurait été ponctuée d'attaqués contre
le personnel depuis le début de la
pandémie
cinq employés de l'équipe des
communications ont quitté leurs
fonctions et deux autres se sont placés
en congé prolongé ce n'est pas la
première vague de départs on est passé
de l'un des milieux de travail les plus
agréables pour les employés à la main en
d or au coeur de la faire le style de
gestion de la gouverneure générale et de
la numéro deux de son bureau son ami de
longue date
l'avocate assunta di lorenzo une source
gouvernementale s'expriment ils vont
vous intimider jusqu'à ce que vous soyez
d'accord ou que vous partiez ce n'est
pas la première fois que des allégations
de climat tendu font surface depuis le
début du mandat de la gouverneure
générale en 2017
j'ai eu affaire à plusieurs
gouvernements au fil des ans et je n'ai
jamais vécu ce genre de traitement
le bureau de la gouverneure générale a
réagi par écrit nous sommes profondément
consterné par la teneur de ce reportage
qui contraste complètement avec la
réalité du travail au bureau de là
1 heure général et occultent le travail
important effectué par notre personnel
dévoué
le bureau du premier ministre écrit tout
canadien a le droit de travailler dans
un environnement sain respectueux et sur
notre gouvernement s'est engagé à faire
en sorte que tous les lieux de travail
sous réglementation fédérale soit exempt
de toute forme de harcèlement mais
renvoie les questions spécifiques sur
ces allégations
au bureau de julie payette cette
situation met en lumière des enjeux de
reddition de comptes et de transparence
au bureau de la gouverneure générale
selon cet expert qui répond aux
critiques c'est vraiment le premier
ministre en tant que chef c'est l'image
de l'une des plus vieilles institutions
du pays qui est en jeu
la gouverneure générale doit être une
figure de stabilité et son rôle est
particulièrement important lorsqu'un
gouvernement est minoritaire en pleine
crise sanitaire est au coeur d'une
controverse éthique
justin trudeau se retrouve avec un autre
problème épineux sur les bras ici louis
blouin radio canada ottawa